It's hard to believe it's been more than 30
years since James Cameron made The Terminator,
but several movies down the line, the franchise
has lost its steam.
Cameron told an amazing story across Terminator
and Terminator II: Judgment Day, but not all
franchises are meant to run for three decades.
Here's a look at why Hollywood won't make
another Terminator movie.
Defective hardware
Let's be real: The past few sequels were pretty
much total train wrecks.
Things started to go downhill with 2003's
Terminator 3: Rise of the Machines, the first
without Cameron at the helm.
“Talk to the hand.”
The decline continued with 2009's Terminator:
Salvation, which despite the presence of splashy
action director McG, somehow managed to make
the future battle with Skynet utterly boring.
“Who are you?”
“John Connor!”
That necessitated the full-on reboot in 2015's
Terminator: Genisys, which was met with such
critical disdain and box office indifference
that planned sequels were cancelled.
Yuck.
Cursed without Cameron
The first two films were awesome for one obvious
reason.
And no, it wasn't naked Arnold Schwarzenegger.
“Your clothes.
Give them to me.
Now.”
So when writer-director James Cameron decided
to leave the franchise after Terminator II:
Judgment Day, Hollywood should have probably
just left well enough alone and ended the
series right there.
It's telling that Cameron says he's not a
"big fan" of the sequels that followed, as
he doesn't feel they "lived up to that potential."
And without Cameron, they probably never will.
Disenfranchised
One big issue with the series is that it wasn't
designed to be a series at all.
Both the original film and Terminator II weren't
really about time travel, but instead focused
on how knowledge of the impending Armageddon
affected the characters.
Sarah Connor found her inner strength, the
Terminator found his humanity, John discovered
his destiny.
No amount of modern special effects can disguise
the fact that the sequels are missing the
heart of the original films.
Instead, they've relied on increasingly bloated,
confusing, and convoluted plots, trading humanity
for incomprehensible spectacle.
Without the original films’ focus on what
it means to be human, the sequels are destined
to be pale imitations rather than worthy successors.
Arn-old
Other than James Cameron, the major driving
force behind the franchise is Arnold Schwarzenegger.
You have to give him credit for suiting up
yet again in Terminator: Genisys despite the
fact that he was pushing 70.
But even he has his limits, and the time is
fast approaching when he'll no longer be able
to pull off a Terminator film.
And would fans really want to see more sequels
without him?
Given how little moviegoers have wanted to
see the last bunch even with him present in
the cast, making more sequels without Arnold
seems like a losing formula.
“I’ll be back.”
Mmm...this time, you probably won't.
Terminator for teens
The first two Terminator films wore their
R ratings like a badge of honor, catering
to adults with dark stories not afraid to
feature some violence and language.
But the last two films diluted the series,
softening enough to earn a PG-13 rating.
That allowed a larger potential audience,
sure, but it also alienated long time fans
by smoothing the title's hard edges and dumbing
down the action.
Pandering is never going to result in better
movies.
“Oh, oh great.
That’s just great.”
“I did not kill him.”
Factory reset
It turns out if you keep churning out bad
movies, the public will eventually stop turning
out to see them.
Who knew?
The past few Terminator films have failed
to generate much box office buzz, despite
ballooning budgets and massive marketing campaigns.
Terminator 3 pulled in $150 million in the
U.S., and it only went downhill from there.
Terminator: Salvation made $125 million in
the U.S., and the latest sequel, Terminator:
Genisys, scored a mere $89 million.
Ouch.
Hollywood leans on known franchises because
they're more bankable brands than unknown
commodities, but sometimes even the name brands
run out of steam.
In the wake of Genisys' failure, the smart
money is sadly no longer on Terminator.
No fate but what we make
Though the situation looks dire now, there's
still hope.
“Come with me if you want to live.”
The reason?
The rights to The Terminator revert back to
Cameron in 2019.
While he's currently busy with those long-promised
Avatar sequels, it's possible he might eventually
make another Terminator film himself.
And if not, you can bet that he'll be very
careful just who he licenses the rights to.
With Cameron regaining creative control over
the franchise, one thing is sure: if there
are never any more Terminator movies, that
also means there won't be any more bad Terminator
movies.
We'll count that as a win.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!